Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube gái Excel bài số
13 các kỹ năng quan trọng khác trước khi
bắt đầu vào bài học ngày hôm nay mình
cùng Giải bài số 12 của hôm trước nhá
đấy các bạn xem ở cái câu hỏi của bài
Sống 12 lên trong bài số 12 mình sẽ làm
ba cái câu nhỏ đầu tiên là người cách
chuyển text thành số thì trong cái bài
trước vị mình đã có cái cách mà mình nên
thấy mùi đúng ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ làm hai
cái cách khác là mình thêm không Và mình
chia cho một đúng không ạ đây ví dụ mình
sẽ điền với số 0 ở ngoài đây là mình sẽ
biến với số 1 ở ngoài nữa đây thì cái
Cách thứ nhất chị mình cho thêm không
vào cái phần doanh thu này đấy ạ Các bạn
sẽ nháy phẳng và cái giá trị không Này
các bạn chọn copy đấy Sau đó các bạn Bôi
đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà các bạn muốn
chuyển nó thành số nha để gọi xinh nhảy
cực phẳng Các bạn chọn gì ạ chọn fast
Castle đấy các phím tắt của Pisa là diện
các bạn giữ phím An này các bạn 4
ạ sau đó bạn vẫn dự phim anh nhắc các
bạn bấm thêm phím f đấy thì nó sẽ hiện
cái cửa sổ Tuyết cho số lên không ạ lại
các bạn sẽ bấm vào cái phím f này tức là
rẻ các doanh thu ở đây sẽ thêm cái số
không mà mình khóc cái lúc đấy vào đấy
thì nó sẽ chuyển về dạng số nhé các bạn
bấm ok đấy thì như vậy toàn bộ giá trị
của mình đã được chuyển về dạng số gặp
lại bây giờ mình sẽ ăn dung á Cái Cách
thứ hai là gì ạ Ngoài thêm không thì các
bạn có thể chia cho một cũng được nhá
đấy các bạn sẽ nghe được phải quá copy
cái giá trị ngủ được đây sau đó bạn Bôi
đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà các bạn muốn
chuyển vào số này các bạn giữ phím An
e&s đấy mình sẽ mở cái cửa sổ Pascal số
lên nhé các bạn sẽ bấm phím mẹ các bạn
có thể chọn cái diz lại tức là các danh
thủ ở đây mình sẽ chia cho một đấy thì
nó sẽ tự động nó sẽ chuyển về kiểu số
đẹp để các bạn xem bấm ok đấy tiếp theo
là gì ạ mình sẽ bớt các cái giá trị vào
cái ô đang có Không ạ Ở đây là các giá
trị mà mình cần bớt không ạ Đây mình cần
bớt doanh thu ví dụ 397 mình sẽ
có 258 thì chả biết hai trăm đấy để làm
việc này các bạn làm như sau nhé các bạn
Bôi đen Cái vùng giá trị mà các bạn muốn
bớt này các bạn nhé bên phải của bạn
copy đấy sau đó hoặc boral cái vùng dữ
liệu mà các bạn muốn - cái phần bớt này
đấy bạn nhé Thì phải các bạn chọn
special Hoặc là các bạn ấn phím tắt là
An này EF đây sau đó bạn chọn cả các bạn
chọn cái xuất xác nhận đây Các bạn bấm
ok thì như vậy toàn bộ cái doanh thu này
nó đã bớt đi cái phần ở bên phải này ạ
khá là hai ông ạ tiếp theo là gì ạ mình
sẽ bớt cái phần trăm trong hội cái giá
trị Ở đây bây giờ giả sử mình có doanh
thu là từng này nhá bây giờ mình muốn
bớt 15 phần trăm các giá trị này Đấy cái
cách mà đơn giản nhất thì mình sẽ biệt ở
đây là 85 phần trăm tức là rẽ các bạn
phải bằng 1
3 - cái phần mà mình muốn Bấp ở đây là
mình bớt 15 Phần trăm đúng không thì các
bạn sẽ - 15 phần trăm đấy thì nó sẽ ra
là gì 85 phần trăm ạ Các bạn sẽ nhấn
chuột phải vào cái ô 85 phần trăm lại
các bạn chọn copy đấy sau đó bọn Boram
cái vùng dữ liệu mà các bạn muốn bớt 15
phần trăm nhá các bạn nháy chuột phải là
các bạn chọn quyết sao rồi đấy và các
bạn chọn con vịt like tức là diện tức là
các cái răng Thủy ở đây mình sẽ nhấn với
cả 85 phần trăm thì bản chất là nó bớt
đi 15 Phần trăm đúng không lấy gạo sẽ
bấm ok thì như vậy toàn bộ cái doanh thu
này đã bữa đi 15 Phần Trăm Khi mà mình
nhân với cả cái giá trị phần trăm ở đây
thì cái số mặc định nó lại chuyển về
phần trăm đúng không thì các bạn vào thẻ
hôm mày có thích vào cái dấu phẩy này
cũng được đấy thì nó sẽ chuyển về cái
giá trị dẫn số bình thường lại vì sau
khi bớt đi 15 phần trăm thì các cái giá
trị doanh thu nó sẽ còn lại từng ngày
nhé
Ừ Ok như vậy là mình đã kết thúc cái
phần câu hỏi của bài số 12 các bạn có
thể đóng lại nhá
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ vào cái bài số 13 của
ngày hôm nay các bạn sẽ mở cái file thực
hành của bài số 13 lên các bạn chú ý
mình sẽ đẻ cái link tải file thực hành
trong phần mô tả phía dưới video thì tốt
nhất là các bạn tải về các bạn mở lên để
vừa theo dõi và thực hành cùng mình nhá
Nếu như bạn nào mà không biết cách tải
về thì các bạn có thể theo dõi Cái bài
đầu tiên thì trong bài đấy mình đã hướng
dẫn rất là chi tiết các cái bước để các
bạn tải về nhá Thì cái file mà các bạn
tải về sẽ làm một cái file nén các bạn
sẽ giải nén ra và nó sẽ có 2 file 1 file
mà file thực hành và một cái còn lại là
cái câu hỏi để các bạn làm bài tập về
nhà nha Đấy trong bài học ngày hôm nay
mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn bốn cái kỹ
năng quan trọng khác là gì ạ Đầu tiên là
phân tích nhanh thứ hai là điền nhanh
thứ ba là cố định tiêu đề và thứ tư là
xóa trùng nhau để tên tiếng Anh của nó
là dịp which allows freshfield fanpage
và rimmel Kate mỗi một kỹ năng ở đây
mình đã để một cái xếp tiếng Việt rồi
nhá
đầu tiên mình sẽ làm cái phần phân tích
nhanh thì giả sử đây là cái vùng dữ liệu
mà các bạn cần phân tích đúng ạ thì các
bạn thấy nhá Ở bên phải mình đã để cái
hướng dẫn chi tiết các bước để làm cái
việc phân tích nhanh này thì các bạn đặc
biệt chú ý cho mình nhá cái công cụ phân
tích nhanh này nó chỉ có từ Excel 2013
trở lên thôi tức là rượu 2013 là 2016 và
2019 thì các bạn có cái công cụ phân
tích nhanh này có những bạn nào mà cài
các bạn Excel cũ hơn như lái xe 2010
hoặc 2007 thì nó sẽ không có nhá thì đầu
tiên để phân tích nhanh để bạn giữa các
bạn Bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu của
mình đấy sau khi bạn Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ
liệu thì các bạn sẽ nhìn xuống dưới góc
bên phải lên này để lo sẽ có một cái ô
vuông nhỏ đây khi mà các bạn trả chuột
vào thì nó sẽ hiện cái chữ request arise
đấy hoặc phím tắt là diện các bạn có thể
bấm can Dương quy để các bạn xúc xích
vào đây Thì như vậy là địa một cái cửa
sổ phân tích nhanh ra được Hiện ra đúng
không nó sẽ có cái thẻ diện đầu tiên là
cái trẻ định dạng rất là mình sẽ định
dạng nhanh này cái thẻ
Ừ để mình sẽ biểu đồ nhanh Đây là cái
công thức để mình tính toán học ví dụ
tính Cẩm tiếng Trung Bình đây ạ Đây đây
là để tạm thay vụ Còn đây là tạo cái đồ
thị farcry Thế là đồ thị nhanh nhất ví
dụ mình bạc với format tinh trước nhé
đây Nếu như các bạn chọn vào cái này K3
đây thì khi các bạn trò chuyện vào đây
thì gọi nhìn Lên xe nhìn trên cái bảng
dữ liệu của mình thì các cái ô nó đã
được tô màu dưới dạng cái đây tao ba để
Tức là cái hiện phần trăm tô màu của cái
ô nó sẽ phụ thuộc vào cái giá trị của nó
đấy giá trị mà càng lớn thì cái diện
tích và nó tô màu sẽ càng nhiều các con
cái karakal là hiện nó cũng tương tự như
vậy thôi chứ làm nó sẽ tô màu tăng hoặc
giảm dần theo cái giá trị Ví dụ như các
bạn nhìn cái số thứ tự kể cả nó sẽ tu từ
đập xuống à đây hoặc là cái icon sét
cũng vậy nhá Nó sẽ thể hiện ở mức tăng
lương giảm hoặc là mức đi nhanh Chắc là
cái kiểu format mà mình có sẵn đây nhá
khoảng cách đồ thị cũng vậy đấy các bạn
có thể chú ý Đầy đây là một số cái đồ
thị mà cơ bản nhất
số của cái phân tích nhanh hoặc làm gì ở
đây là cái tô tờ tức là có thể tính tổng
này tính trung bình này cao này đấy hoặc
là tính hiện phần trăm vô tờ hoặc là
running Total bây giờ ví dụ như tích của
xăm đi đấy thì đoạn thấy cho khi gọi
thích là xong thì bạn đấy à Đây là tổng
của các tần số thứ tự đúng không thì
thông thường với số thứ tự 2 cái giới
tính là mình không cần giải trí ngay lập
tức ở đây mình đã có cái phần phân tích
nhanh rồi nhá lại bây giờ còn xóa đi Ví
dụ Các bạn có thể tạo các phân tích
nhanh khác lại gọn Bôi đen lại các bạn
thích vào đây và các bạn bấm Căn cứ Quy
nhé ví dụ mình vẫn khi tắt là Căn cứ Quy
đi đấy thì nó sẽ hiện một cái bảng phân
tích nhanh ví dụ mình chọn cái đồ thị đi
đấy các bạn trỏ và cái phần đồ thị này
nhá Ví dụ mình thích mở ra đấy thì nó có
cái đồ thị diện nó có đồ thị về ba cái
môn học ở lý thuyết thực hành và tổng
điểm đây là của các nhân viên này đoạn
theo khá là hay ạ thì tùy vào cái mục
đích của các bạn là các bạn chọn cái
phần phân tích nhanh nhé Ok xanh chỉ
năng thứ hai là cái
ở trong Excel thì cái này thực sự là rất
là hay với những các bạn nào mà hay phải
sử dụng mà các bạn Chiết xuất số liệu
các bạn cần Ví dụ như cần tách họ tên
này Hoặc mình cần tắt ngày tháng này
hoặc là mình cần tách một cái gì đấy
trong các chuỗi của mình thì mình sẽ
dùng cái khác yêu này nhá thì trong cái
bài học này mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn
lăn cái ví dụ cụ thể của cái flash phim
ấy thì các bạn thứ nhất các thì nó sẽ có
từ cái phiên bản Excel 2013 trở về sau
không lấy còn những cái access Cũ Như
Excel 2010 và 2007 thì nó sẽ không có
đâu nhá các bạn lưu ý cho mình nó như
vậy nếu như bạn nào và đang dùng cái
Excel 2010 hoặc 2007 hay là có những bạn
dùng Excel 2003 thì các bạn cần nâng cấp
lên nhá thì tốt nhất là chọn cả lên
Excel 2016 hoặc 2019 nhé Ok mình sẽ đi
vào cái ví dụ đầu tiên của mình có danh
sách Họ tên đầy đủ nha của các bạn này
Bây giờ mình cần tách họ và tách tên thì
mình làm như thế nào ạ Các bạn chỉ cần
gõ cái họ của một bạn ở trên này thôi ví
dụ đây là ca vẫn cố túc
Em chỉ cần gõ tiếp cao phải gọi enter
thì gì ạ Excel đã sẽ tự hiểu là gì mình
nói sẽ chết sức cái từ đầu tiên của cái
trường họ tên ở đây đấy xin để sử dụng
Flash nhá thì làm gì Các bạn có thể bấm
kahchan e luôn lại Ví dụ mình bấm trang
cho em luôn này Đấy Cậu thấy chưa sau
khi các bạn Bống tensione thì nó sẽ tự
hiểu Cái tên còn lại nó sẽ được tách
phần Họ đây để rất là hai ạ Cái Phần Tên
cũng vậy nha ví dụ tên ở đây các bạn chỉ
cần gõ cái tên đầu tiên thôi mình gọi
cho cốt ở đây thôi lại gọi enter Bây giờ
con Bôi đen này sau đó diện các bạn vào
thẻ đã ta nhé các bạn chọn cái Classic ở
đây đấy thì như vậy là điện toàn bộ cái
vùng dữ liệu tên ở đây đã được viện đã
được liền nhanh cao thấy không Lúc này
cái việc tách họ tên của mình quá là đơn
giản hơn đúng ạ Đấy Ok cái ví dụ thứ hai
là diện giả sửa đây mình có tên đầy đủ
nhá bây giờ mình muốn viết tắt thôi Chả
sửa đây mình cần diện mình cần ghép các
các ký tự đầu tiên của họ này tên đệm và
tên đấy ví dụ Cao Văn cuốn các bạn Quyền
gõ cv
Ừ để con enter để bây giờ có còn vào thẻ
data Các bạn chọn flash kêu đấy thì nó
cũng lập tức là nó sẽ tiền nhanh luôn là
cái tên két sắt ở đây lợi ích sao nó rất
là thông minh nó hiểu là diện Long hiểu
là các bạn sẽ lấy 3 cái ký tự đầu tiên
của ba cái chữ Cao Văn cốt này cảm thấy
không Đây là Bùi Thị béo là BTV lấy Đỗ
Văn Đậu là DVD là khá là hay ạ Con ở đây
là dịp mình có họ và tên đệm Đây là cái
phần tên bây giờ mình muốn gộp vào đúng
ạ Đấy thì con làm dễ các bạn chỉ cần gõ
tên đầy đủ đây là diện Cao Văn cốt đây
các bạn enter bây giờ các bạn muốn phím
tắt là cân dẫn em nhé cảm thấy chưa thì
nó sẽ tự động điền cái phần điện nó sẽ
gồm họ và tên vào thành cái họ tên đầy
đủ đây này rất là hay ạ Tiếp theo là cái
phần giới tí nhá Đấy thì ở đây mình có
cái chiều thông tin là họ tên và cái
phần giới tính thì các bạn thấy nhắc cái
phần giới tính ở đây p Thì nghĩa là con
trai giờ thì là con gái đúng không Đấy
bây giờ để lấy cái
Ừ thì gọi thì gọi Thiết ở đây thôi thấy
gọi m bây giờ các bạn sẽ dùng cái
freshview nhá các bạn bốn ca cho me đấy
thì khi mà các bạn muốn căn ke đây nó sẽ
báo lỗi ngay tại vì sao ạ Tại vì bạn chú
ý này cái tê ở đây thì nó lại không hiểu
là cái giới tính tôi là cái chữ t cuối
cùng mà nó lại hiểu là cái chữ t đầu
tiên à Cho nên cái phần giới tính ở đây
nó lại lấy cái ký tự đầu tiên của cái
chữ họ của cái phần họ này đấy còn thế
không như vậy cái phần flash này các bạn
hết sức khỏe chuối cho mình nhá Nếu
nhưng mà cái kết quả đấy nó chưa Đúng
như cái ý của mình thì các bạn sẽ thêm
một cái mẫu nữa đúng không Thì ở đây các
bạn có thể gõ chứ t tiếp nữa đấy thì khi
vặn gọi tên này thì nó chỉ có duy nhất
trước đây ở đây thôi đấy các em tư một
cái thì toàn bộ cái phần còn lại nó sẽ
tự động nó sẽ được viện thay thế lại tức
là sau khi mà các bạn thêm một cái mẫu
thứ hai nữa thì nó mới hiểu là gì ạ nó
mới hiểu là bạn lấy cái ký tự cuối cùng
của cái phần họ tên là đây tức là dễ
tính đấy Thông thường các bạn sẽ
chị xem nào một hai cái trường hợp đầu
tiên xem nó đã đúng chưa Nếu như nó đúng
rồi thì các bạn hãy dùng cái flash nhé
Ok ví dụ cuối cùng của cái flash Fill
điện mình sẽ lấy 5 và tháng giả sửa đây
mình có cái trường ngày tháng nhá lại
bây giờ mình muốn lấy 5 và tháng thì
mình là như thế nào năm ở đấy thì các
bạn sẽ biển là 2005 thôi đấy Gọi enter
bây giờ các bạn chỉ cần bấm vào chỗ này
thôi thì lập tức sao nó sẽ hiểu là nó sẽ
lấy năm của các ô còn lại rất là hai ạ
Cái tháng cũng vậy nhá thì ở đây là
tháng 11 đúng không các bạn chui ngã ở
đây mình đã đổi các định dạng là gì ạ
Ngày trước Tháng sau và đến năm rồi đó
đấy thì khi mà các bạn có tháng 11 ở đây
nhá lại các em từ nhà thì ít sao lại
hiểu cái 11 ở đây là cái 11 đầu tiên ở
đây tức là lấy ngày chứ không phải thánh
vậy cho nên các bạn khi mà con Bống cân
cho em nhé đấy Bạn thấy chứ Tôi bảo nó
đã lấy ngày chứ ngoài tháng đúng không
Bây giờ mình sẽ lưu lại đấy thì cho lên
ý trong trường hợp này các bạn phải lấy
thêm một cái mẫu nữa tôi là các bạn phải
gọi cho 10 đây nữa
em nghĩ xem nó mới hiểu là cái ông này
ông ấy tháng đúng không ạ Bây giờ còn
chỉ cần 4kcal thôi đấy thì đã hiểu là
các bạn ấy tháng rồi Rất là hay đây là
tháng 3 này tháng 5 là tháng 5 tháng 5
tháng 5 rồi đấy thì như vậy cái
Flashtool đó sẽ có hai cái chú ý một là
gì ạ Cái flash nó chỉ hỗ trợ từ Excel
2013 trở lên thôi Và thứ hai là gì ạ nếu
như bạn dùng cái class chứ Thì bạn phải
chú ý cho mình trong một số trường hợp
Ví dụ như trường hợp này các bạn phải
thêm các cái mẫu khác nhau thì nó mới
hiểu đúng Cái ý của bạn đấy có những cái
trường hợp nếu như bạn không thêm mỗi
thì nó sẽ hiểu sai ý của các bạn ạ Đấy
Ok xanh cái thứ ba là rẻ mình sẽ cố định
cái vùng tiêu đề thì giả sử kết dữ liệu
của mình ở đây là liệu mình có cái danh
sách sản phẩm rất là nhiều sản phẩm
không ạ Còn đây là các cách ngày trong
tháng không ạ Giả sử đây là mình đang
lấy dữ liệu của tháng 3 đúng không để
các bạn xem đây là cái tan iPhone 3 Dọn
sẽ tăng đây thì là gì À cái dữ liệu của
mình nó được Lan sang bên phải này để nó
sẽ đến cái ngày cuối cùng của cái tháng
3 là ban
ạ Bây giờ các bạn lại lăn về đầu ở đây
đấy tương tự cái phần sản phẩm của mình
có rất là nhiều Đúng không các bạn muốn
kiểm tra các sản phẩm cuối cùng thì các
bạn lại lăn xuống hoặc các bạn kéo cái
con chuột này đấy thì như vậy khi con
kéo xuống ấy hoặc các bạn có dám phải
thì bạn sẽ không nhìn thấy cái phần tiêu
đề nữa đúng không đấy thì nó sẽ rất khó
cho mình biết là cái dữ liệu nào là của
ngày nào thì bây giờ mình phải cố định
cái cùng tiêu đề của mình thì cái vùng
tiêu đề của mình sẽ gồm hai cái tiêu đề
là tiêu đề hàng và tiêu đề cột đấy để cố
định cái phần tiêu đề hàng nha tí là
mình muốn cố định cái hàng thứ 8 này thì
các bạn có thích vào cái hàng dưới nó
Tức là thích vào cái hàng thứ 9 này lại
sau đó bạn vào cái thẻ diện các bạn vào
cái thẻ view để các bạn chọn phim Pain
và các bạn chọn cái đầu tiên là cái
phiên luôn ở đây đấy thì như vậy là
Thiện nó sẽ cố định trước cái hàng mà
mình chọn là thứ 9 thì nó sẽ cố định từ
cái hành số 8 trở lên để bây giờ các bạn
lăn cái con chuột để xuống con thấy chưa
thì như vậy là cái hành số 8 luôn cố
định thì
anh ở đây thì các bạn biết là cái giá
trị này nó là của cái ngày nào cũng là
con thấy không rất là hai ạ cái tiêu đề
này luôn luôn cố định rồi bây giờ để bỏ
cái cố định cái phần tiêu đề là gì ạ rồi
thì các bạn chỉ cần tĩnh lại và cái thẻ
ghi này các bạn tích vào cái feel Pain
và các bạn chọn vào đây là Ân Phi bên
đây tức là trước đã mình đã pin rồi thì
bây giờ nó sẽ đổi thành cái Ân phía bên
này đây lại cậu thích vào đây Thì như
vậy cái phần tiêu đề luôn đã không được
cố định nữa đấy gọi thêm rất là hai ạ
tương tự bây giờ để cố định cái vùng
tiêu đề cho các phần cột Tức là mình
muốn cố định cho các phần sản phẩm là
cái cột bên này đúng ạ thì các bạn phải
thích vào cái cột C này Đấy tức là mình
phải tích sang phải một cột so với cái
cột mà mình muốn cố định đúng không Đấy
sau đó còn vào thẻ Miu Các bạn chọn phê
và các bạn tích tiếp và cái khuôn viên ở
đây để thì như vậy là cái cột b này đã
được cố định đổi về các bạn lăng cái con
chuột này sang đây còn thấy chưa thì như
vậy cái cột b này luôn luôn cố định Khi
các bạn tích vào đấy thì bạn biết ngay
nào làm
A và doanh thu của sản phẩm số bạch đấy
Bạn thấy không rất là hay luôn đấy cái
cột bên này luôn cố định các bạn vào cái
thẻ view các bạn flipper các bạn bỏ cái
cố định tiêu đề đây nhá Ok bây giờ trong
trường hợp mà mình muốn cố định nghĩa là
hàng và cả cột thì mình là như thế nào
Okay cùng năm sau đây này Đấy nó không
cố định nữa đúng không với các bạn Năm
xuống đây này Đấy nó nó không cố định
nữa Bây giờ mình muốn cố định nghĩa cả
cái hành số 8 này và cả cái cột bên này
thì mình là như thế nào thì các bạn phải
chọn một cái ô mà nó sẽ hiện nó phải
dưới cái hành số 8 và nó ở bên phải cái
cột mà mình muốn cố định đúng không Tức
là cái ô C9 đây này lại thì khi các bạn
thích mẫu C9 hãy thì cái hàng tôi chí
này nó sẽ nằm dưới cái thằng số 8 và cái
cột C này nó sẽ làm ở bên phải cột b này
đây đấy tôi là mình rất thích vào đấy ạ
Các bạn sẽ thích vào cái Ok chí này nhá
sau đó còn bảo thể Milk Các bạn chọn pp
và các bạn thích vào cái bên này luôn
đấy khi bạn nắm súng này cảm thấy chưa
cái phần tiêu
chị đã được cố định và khi bạn 50 phải
lại đấy thì cái cột b này cũng được cố
định phải gọi thêm rất là hai cái này là
mình sẽ cố định cả hàng và cả cột nhá Ok
sang kỹ năng thứ tư là mình xóa trùng
nhau cái này cũng rất là nhiều bạn hay
dùng đấy thì giả sử mình có thông tin ở
đây là gì ạ Cái khu vực này năm sản phẩm
và doanh thu đấy thì con Thúy nha các
khu vực ở đây Thực ra nó chỉ có 3 khu
vực thôi và các sản phẩm ở đây Thực ra
nó cũng chỉ có 3 sản phẩm thôi nhưng mà
diện nó kết hợp của khu vực năm và sản
phẩm đâm ra nó có rất là nhiều cái
trường bây giờ giả sử mình muốn lọc
nghiện các khu vực duy nhất thì mình làm
như thế nào thì để lọc các cách khu vực
thứ nhất thì gọi sẽ poland cái cột khu
vực này này các bạn nháy chuột phải các
bạn copy đấy ví dụ mình copy ra một cái
cột ca này chẳng á thì cậu thích vào
cuộc ta gọi lấy được phải gắn kết với đã
đấy thì như vậy cái cục ga này hiện nó
sẽ copy toàn bộ cái khu vực ở cột bên
này đúng không các bạn xuất tinh bằng
cái Coca này nhá Đấy sau đó bọn vào thẻ
data là các bạn chọn remove Plus liên
kết
Ừ thì một cái cửa sổ đi mua bút mới kết
hiện ra đúng không đấy thì ở đây nó chỉ
có một cột là cột ca thôi đúng không Thì
nó ở đây nó thích và cụ tra thì gọi cho
bấm ok thì như vậy là gì ạ Nó sẽ hiện
của cái cửa sổ thông báo là việc 15 cái
giá trị là trùng nhau được tìm thấy và
nó sẽ Gmobile và nó chỉ bớt lại ba cái
giá trị duy nhất thôi Các bạn bấm ok thì
như vậy Ba cái giá trị duy nhất ở đây là
gì Bắc Trung Nam để gặp thêm rất là hai
ạ bây giờ ví dụ bị xóa đi nhá thì ok Giả
sử mình sẽ dùng cái Limo đúc kết cho cái
vùng giá trị này đi bây giờ mình muốn
bớt lại rẻ mình cũng bớt lại cái khu vực
và sản phẩm đúng ạ Tức là miền Nam thì
có bao nhiêu sản phẩm Miền Trung thì bao
nhiêu sản phẩm và miền Bắc thì bao nhiêu
sản phẩm mình không quan tâm với trường
năm và trường doanh thu thì mình làm như
thế nào thì ok Giả sử mình chất tích và
mô bất kỳ trong cây vùng dữ liệu này nhá
Sau đó các bạn gọi thì ra ta Các bạn
chọn remove đúc kết này đấy thì một cái
cửa sổ ghi mô đúc kết hiện ra đúng không
Thì bạn chú ý cho mình nhá Ở đây làm gì
mình có bốn cái cột là khu vực 5 sản
Ừ thì nó sẽ tương ứng là 40k lần khu vực
sản phẩm và doanh thu đúng ạ Đấy thì mặc
định là gì nó sẽ tích và bốn cái ô này
nghĩa là gì khi các bạn tích vào 40 ôn
này thì nó sẽ dùng nhom hết thì nó mới
xóa đây nhá Bây giờ giả sử Minh tích và
4 ô này con thích Ok Đấy nó sẽ báo là
Thiện không có cái giá trị nào trùng
nhau cả Tức là không có cái giá trị là
trùng nhau cả về khu vực cả về năm cả về
sản phẩm và cả về doanh thu đấy Bây giờ
các bạn hãy thích lại mà ông bất kỳ Các
bạn chọn với mua đúc kết nhá Bây giờ giả
sử mình chỉ chọn cái khu vực và sản phẩm
thôi đúng không các bạn sẽ thích cái
inspection này này thì nó sẽ bỏ chọn tất
cả đi Sau đó mình sẽ chọn khu vực và sản
phẩm thôi chứ cả Thiện nó chỉ quan tâm
đến khu vực và sản phẩm trùng nhau thì
nó sẽ xóa nó sẽ không quan tâm đến năm
và doanh thu năm bao nhiêu hay là kênh
Thu bao nhiêu thì nó cũng không quan tâm
mà nó chỉ quan tâm và khu vực và sản
phẩm cứ trùng nhau thì nó sẽ xóa các bạn
sẽ bấm ok để các bạn Ok thì như vậy là
gì ạ Nó chỉ còn bớt lại ở đây là gì ạ
ở những cái giá trị thôi như vậy mỗi khu
vực sẽ có 3 sản phẩm đúng không Vậy Nam
Trung Bắc là sản phẩm Một này Nam Trung
Bắc là sản phẩm hay và nam Trung Bắc là
sản phẩm ba đấy thì như vậy là liệu mỗi
một khu vực nó sẽ có 3 sản phẩm thì nó
sẽ tẩm còn lại là diện nó sẽ còn lại 9
cái hàng dữ liệu ở đây giả sử các bạn
aloo lại nhá lại các bạn sẽ chọn lại mua
nút liên kết Nếu như mà các bạn ăn
silicone này mà các bạn chỉ chọn cái sản
phẩm Thôi thì là gì ở nó chỉ quan tâm
sản phẩm trùng nhau thì bác xóa vào nó
sẽ không quan tâm đến khu vực thuê hàng
năm hay là Doanh thu là thế nào nha các
bạn cũng ok thì như vậy Ở đây là gì Ok
Như Vậy chỉ còn ba cái sản phẩm là sản
phẩm một sản phẩm hay và sản phẩm ba
thôi Đấy mình sẽ ăn đi nhé có chửi nhé
nó đi mu như thế nào thì tức là gì ạ Giả
sử Lúc nãy mình đi mua cho sản phẩm nha
đây Các bạn chọn cái vung bút ký kết này
các bạn ăn silicone mình chọn sản phẩm
nhé đấy thì là gì ạ Nó sẽ xem xét sản
phẩm từ trên xuống dưới cứ sản phẩm là
một mà trùng nhau thì nó sẽ xóa cái sản
phẩm dưới này
a bít lại cái sản phẩm một đầu tiên đấy
Tức là cái sản phẩm 01 đầu tiên nhé thì
nợ là khu vực phía Nam đúng không Thì nó
sẽ bớt ra cái hàng đầu tiên này để tiếp
theo là cái sản phẩm 02 nha thì nó sẽ
bớt lại cái sản phẩm 02 đầu tiên ở đây
rất là rẻ khu vực miền Trung và sản phẩm
02 còn các sản phẩm 03 là phía Nam đầu
tiên thì nó sẽ bớt đại diện phía Nam và
giải 103 thấy gặp phân tích Ok bạn sẽ
thấy là đấy Bạn thấy chưa Nam Trung Nam
đấy thì nó sẽ giữ lại cái hàng đầu tiên
đấy còn thấy ông khá là hay ạ thì như
vậy mình đã kết thúc cái bài học của
ngày hôm nay bây giờ mình sẽ xem cái
phần câu hỏi của phần bài tập về nhà nhá
lấy đoạn mở cái phần tôi hỏi lên chạy
thì câu hỏi của mình là rẻ Mình chỉ cần
dùng cái flash chưa Thôi thì để các bạn
luyện cho các bạn quen lại đấy các bạn
sẽ Tách cái họ tên ở đây và các bạn xem
cách chọn năm vào tháng ở đây nhá đấy
thì cái bài tập về nhà để qua luyện cái
Flashtool này bởi vì cái lắc như là khá
là hay đấy bây giờ
Ừ Ok như vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học
ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã
theo dõi các bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập
nhật video mới nhất của gà cũng như chia
sẻ để giúp mọi người cùng học Excel nhé
Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại ở